he had been pacing back and forth all
night so many hours spent walking to and
fro in his quarters that his feet were
starting to develop painful blisters yet
Jace couldn't bring himself to stay
still after his unsettling Discovery
over the course of the night it had
driven him almost mad but it wasn't just
the fear of the inevitable Calamity he
had learned of that was keeping him up
and worrying him into a state of near
Insanity it was the LIE the smoke screen
that had been used to cover up the truth
and it came all the way from the top
Jace Jacoby had been working as a
researcher within the SCP Foundation for
the better part of a decade sure it
wasn't an easy job at the best of times
in fact it could be dirty dangerous and
even downright deadly were but Jace had
learned to take comfort in the bigger
picture and it cultivated in him a
loyalty for the foundation and what they
stood for the reassuring knowledge that
he was playing but once small part in
protecting the world from anomalous
threats usually helped him sleep a
little easier at night this was not one
of those nights completely by accident
the researcher had learned of a terrible
truth he'd seen a lot of horrible things
while working at the foundation from one
horrific endlessly regenerating
omnicidal reptile to a monstrous
creature comprised primarily of giant
teeth protruding from its body but what
he had uncovered in the depths of the
SCP foundation's own archive terrified
him for a whole different reason because
it seemed to undo every good thing Jace
and all the other Personnel had done in
the name of the foundation he believed
that they were the good guys that their
efforts were to prevent total Global
destruction instead it turned out that
they were just pawns being familiar with
a whole filing cabinet's worth of
special containment procedures for
various anomalies Jace was familiar with
the term 220 Calabasas it even almost
been considered to receive high enough
security clearance to be given the full
details as to what it entailed he was
aware already that it was the name given
to a process that was required to be
performed by Foundation staff as a way
to keep
scp-2317 actively contained
scp-2317 was a wooden door leading to
another dimension or at least it
appeared to be after accessing some
restricted files a suppressed secondary
level of information hidden underneath
the scp-2317 entry Jace discovered what
was really going on
scp-2317 was in part a door to another
world as its nickname suggested but that
wasn't the whole story Beyond the Door
lay a Baron's salt plane the only
structure is visible for Miles being
seven identical Stone pillars with
ancient symbols carved into their
surface frequently a small group of
foundation personnel and security staff
would be sent into
scp-2317 each one of them given a
specific specific role to undertake as
they performed 220 Calabasas that
process required for active containment
was more like an occult ritual involving
holy water an obsidian edged knife
chants that invoked ancient powerful
gods and a chicken to act as a live
sacrifice if Jace had just learned those
specifics of 220 Calabasas he wouldn't
have realized that the ritual was
actually a phony even a pretty
convincing one at that buried beneath
the pillars was chained something of
unspeakable unknowable power it had gone
by many names each invoking a
particularly nasty sense of trepidation
The Sire of tyranny
or simply the Devourer of Worlds the 220
Calabasas ritual was supposedly a way to
keep the Beast locked below to
strengthen the seven chains each
latching the ancient monstrosity to the
pillars above except it didn't it was a
smoke screen the ritual did nothing to
keep the shackles of the the Devourer
intact there was but one chain remaining
one more tether keeping the ancient
Beast caged and over the years no matter
how many times the foundation performed
220 Calabasas it was eroding getting
weaker and weaker it was inevitable the
Devourer of Worlds would one day be free
and yet that wasn't even the worst part
about what Jace had uncovered what could
possibly be worse than learning an
Eldritch deity intent on furling Doom
couldn't be contained with the one
method the foundation had while it was
at the foundation new it had known for a
long time that 220 Calabasas was nothing
more than a charade with all the
effectiveness of a Band-Aid over a
broken leg as if that wasn't bad enough
Jace had traced the source of this
cover-up right to the very top to the
highest operational level within the SCP
foundation's hierarchy the o5 council
was responsible they had known for a
long long time about the ineffectiveness
of two 20 Calabasas and yet hadn't
pursued any more permanent solutions to
the looming threat posed by a cp2317 and
the Devourer after a sleepless night
Jace could hold it in no longer he had
to tread carefully given how far out the
chain this conspiracy went it was hard
to know who to trust something had to be
done that much was clear to him whether
that involved sealing or outright
destroying
scp-2317 but if those tasked with
overseeing the entire Foundation were in
on this cover-up then Jace had to be
extremely careful about who he went to
for help there was only one person he
was certain he could rely on and share
his findings with in secrecy senior
researcher Alice had long been a good
friend of Jace's in fact he'd even go so
far as to say Ellis was his only real
friend within the foundation the more
experienced member of personnel had
practically mentored Jacoby from his
earliest days as an SCP researcher Ellis
had helped him get to grips with certain
diff difficult containment procedures
and even taken the fall for Jace after
some of his early mistakes nearly caused
a Containment Breach researcher Alice's
seniority meant he only got away with a
metaphorical slap on the wrist but most
crucially for Jace right now Ellis
wasn't a high enough rank to be even
close to any of the upper echelon
Foundation doctors like Dr bright or Dr
gears nor was he senior enough to have
any direct dealings with the o5 council
if there was anyone working at the
foundation that Jace could possibly
confide in about his findings regarding
the truth behind
scp-2317 and 220 Calabasas it was Alice
and maybe between them the pair could
put their heads together and avert the
catastrophe of the devourer's inevitable
Escape Jace was nervously pacing back
and forth while Ellis's allies were
glued to the terminal in his quarters he
had shown him a saved copy of the full
archive entry on scp-2317 detailing
everything not just the steps required
to perform to 220 Calabasas but the
additional information about the ritual
not working and that the o5 council knew
it after a long painful wait for
researcher Alice to scan through the
entire file he leaned back from the
terminal screen and sighed well this is
hardly ideal he stated matter-of-factly
hardly ideal Jace echoed his fear of
what all this meant manifesting itself
as a frustrated Outburst I think you
might be underestimating it a little
there Ellis this isn't just some mild
inconvenience we've now got to live with
we're talking about the end of the world
as we know it XK class and on top of
that the council knows it's coming and
are doing nothing about it instead
they're making these high clearance
Personnel go and pointlessly Slaughter
chickens and recite meaningless prayers
about Seven Seals Seven Rings seven
Thrones for the Scarlet King Jacoby
calmed down Alice replied strongly let's
talk about this rationally for all we
know this file here could be a part of
scp-2317's containment procedures that's
what I'm saying the procedure is
ineffective he argued let me finish the
senior researcher responded calmly we
know of dozens of other anomalies that
employ info hazardous or mimetic effects
and sometimes it's not uncommon for
entities of such nature with
capabilities to infect information
itself to be combated via the use of
deliberate necessary
misinformation this file might not even
be an accurate description of scp-2317
it could easily be a method for
containing something else now that
doesn't Jace paused holding his forehead
sorry all this has given me a headache
could I trouble you for some water of
course Ellis answered he got up from a
seat and filled the plastic cup from a
cooler in his quarters while his back
was turned Jacoby didn't see Alice slip
something into the water thanks Alice
Chase said as he gulped down the whole
cup like I was saying that theory of it
being memetic threat doesn't make sense
you've seen scp-2317 from a distance we
both have it's a physical dimensional
Gateway I mean a or to another world is
literally its code name for God's sake
why would there be a real door with an
intangible info Hazard behind it Ellis
stroked his chin pondering quietly for a
moment Jace's Vision seemed to get a
little blurry but he blinked it away
okay so if we take everything in the
scp-2317 file is Gospel then answer me
this what do you propose we do about it
his mentor asked we have to think
radically together I think you and I
need to come up with an alternate
permanent solution to the impending
threat posed by scp-2317 then we present
it to the o5 council storm into their
chamber if necessary and demand them to
implement it the next 220 Calabasas is
scheduled for a few hours from now we
need to bring them something that will
actually work not just that performative
pantomime they put on as a smoke screen
otherwise Alice Jace paused for a moment
hearing his own voice crack with despair
if we don't the Devourer is going to
destroy everything thing you said the
words permanent solution elaborate for
me please Ellis responded look I think
we have only two options the frightened
researcher said Jace noticed he was
starting to feel drowsy lightheaded even
aiding to shake himself to stay upright
and conscious we either find a way to
seal scp-2317 or we destroy the door to
another world outright the 220 Calabasas
procedure that no Rich
ritual they take a one kiloton nuke and
with um in case of containment failure
right we detonate one of those inside
the dimension pray that it kills the
devour
worlds then we shut the door and blow
blow that up the eyes two suddenly
Jace's legs gave out underneath him like
they couldn't support his body weight
anymore he landed on the floor with a
thud while Ellis loomed over him with a
sympathetic look on his line face
here he's drunk me Jace barely managed
to get the question out I'm sorry Jacoby
Ellis side believe me when I say I would
have preferred to talk you out of these
seditious thoughts the duty to the
foundation comes first you understand
the door opened Bevy clumping of boots
against the floor Jace could barely turn
to see the squad of security guards
entering the room they lifted his body
up off the ground getting limper by the
second and began dragging him out by his
arms with all his waning strength he
kicked and thrashed his legs as they
trailed beneath him being taken away by
the guards JC yelled for his mentor's
help he kept trying until his voice
became slurred imperceptible sounds not
even words anymore the world around him
started sinking into darkness as
whatever he'd been dosed with took full
effect as Jace was hauled off struggling
not once did Alice dare to look him in
the eye Jay said no idea how much time
had passed only that he'd been
chemically knocked unconscious for most
of it opening his heavy eyelids he had
no idea where he was the room around him
was in Pitch Darkness for a second he'd
wondered if he'd been executed by the
foundation and was currently dead his
Consciousness trapped in an endless Inky
void then another concerning thought
pushed its way into his head had they
thrown him into the Devourer of world's
prison was a cruel callous move even for
the SCP Foundation to offer Jace up as a
sacrifice for daring to look further
into the truth behind
scp-2317 the column of light cut through
the dark from somewhere above him
leaming down so bright that it was hard
to look directly at it the spotlight did
little to illuminate the rest of the
room although squinting in the dark the
researcher could detect the outlines of
several figures sat in a circle facing
him 13 of them to be exact with one
extra taking their seat he was just
awake enough to remember a crucial
detail that explained where he was there
were 13 members of the o5 counts muscle
along with one administrator hello again
researcher Jacoby came a voice from one
of the seats encircling him tell us do
you know why you're here you Jay
stuttered before his fear once again
erupted in an explosive Outburst you all
knew about scp-2317 you had us perform
220 Calabasas time and time again
knowing that it was doing nothing to
keep the Devourer contained if that
creature gets loose no when it does it
will destroy everything and everyone the
foundation is meant to contain anomalies
not pretend to we have a duty to every
adult child on this planet to protect
them from this entity do not exposit the
foundation's mandates to us Jacoby
another of the council member's voices
replied sounding not in the least bit
concerned if anything they sounded bored
the SCP Foundation acts in accordance
with svato Council dictates not by that
have a moral framework you have chosen
to impose on this organization but the
Devourer of world is coming Jace pleaded
you all know as much I I've seen it in
the scp-2317 file inevitable you used
that exact word we are aware of the
threat faced by
scp-2317-k or the Devourer as you called
it a third council member interjected
but rest assured at the time 220
Calabasas was established to provide an
illusion of containment we calculated it
would take several decades for the final
chain holding the creature to give way
that time might have already elapsed the
researcher argued and in the meantime we
have no countermeasures prepared no
strategy and the rest of the Personnel
have no idea that this threat is coming
almost exactly the same wording as last
time one council member said not
addressing the rest directly but still
just audible enough for Jace to detect
it what do you mean last time yes
thinking back a few short moments to the
beginning of this exchange wait what why
did you say hello again when I woke up
here there was a horrible nauseating
silence throughout the room for a moment
Jace had already worked out the answer
why would the council bother telling him
the truth now I've figured this out
before haven't I he said a handful of
times one of the voices replied if not
use and another member of personnel
every now and then someone snoops and
kind of something they shouldn't and you
make them forget it Jace finishes their
sentence for them before he applies
gymnastics the voice said observe today
is 220 calibes procedures are ready
underway a huge curved screen blinked to
life it filled half the circumference of
the room but wasn't enough to give Jace
any clearer of a look at the o5 council
each one of them was cast as shadowy
silhouetted figures against the images
now appearing on the screen it was
footage being streamed live from one of
the Personnel cleared to enter
scp-2317 they were already in the middle
of Performing the phony ritual spritzing
holy water over the Seven Pillars
unaware that one of them was still
linked to a chain keeping the Devourer
imprisoned below oh suddenly there was a
rumbling a shaking reverberating through
the ground on the video feed like an
earthquake or something moving
underneath oh my
Chase breathed as he watched in horror
it's happening the Devourer is coming
now get them out of there some of the
o5s mumbled awkwardly to themselves we
shouldn't act with too much haste it
could just be the creature reacting to
the ritual one hypothesized it's been
imprisoned for a lot longer than a lot
of us have lived it's bound to get
Restless another concurred besides the
security team are armed with a nuclear
device in case the West should happen on
the screen the Tremors were continuing
the Personnel member in charge of
applying the holy water dropped the
silver aspergillom and asporium
containing it spilling its contents Over
The Salted earth below without any
further warning the ground started to
crumble in the feed an enormous clawed
hand bursting up from underground it was
followed by the hulking shape of
something much larger breaking through
the salt plane sending a tidal wave
towards the Personnel member whose body
cam footage was being displayed the feed
cut out and the room was dark once again
it's too late Jace stared at the council
in a mix of Terror and disgust you did
nothing and now it's too late before any
of them could reply another Tremor rang
out this time beneath Jace's own feet
the Devourer of Worlds was here it was
bursting through the wooden door of
scp-2317 and tearing the foundation
facility apart with its immense size as
it emerged the walls cracked the entire
building beginning to crumble around him
and the o5 council who were all
hurriedly exiting the chamber to
whatever plans or bunkers they had to
ensure their own personal survival
suddenly the huge weight of something
dropped through the dark and collapsed
on top of Jace standing up amongst the
wreckage of the obliterated building the
Devourer of Worlds Drew itself up to its
full height it was an impossibly large
creature humanoid and obese its entire
body was covered head to toe in thick
armored scales with horns atop its
jawless head from one of them hung the
final chain a withered shackle no longer
keeping the monster held within its
underground prison the seven chains had
all failed the ritual 220 Calabasas had
failed in fact it never worked in the
first place far below his arms pinned
painfully under a heavy slab of concrete
Jace stared up at the Towering form of
the Devourer he had felt scared as the
building came down around him and even
now there was a lingering fear of his
own death but there was something else
there too a sense of feeling oddly
relieved not necessarily glad to be
right about the impending doom or even
pleased to know this ancient trap deity
was about to destroy the whole planet
but at least the Devourer of Worlds was
honest he thought there was no
subterfuge no rituals acting as a smoke
screen no more lies just an honest
Simplicity of a creature whose only goal
was to bring an end to everything as
Jace watched the Devourer raised its
hands up reaching the highest Pinnacle
of the sky then brought them straight
back down to earth it plumbed both deep
into the skin of the world deep enough
to crack the very surface open mantle
and magma were spewing everywhere like
blood from the gaping wounds had left in
the planet Jace Jacoby closed his eyes
as the ground beneath where he lay
trapped ripped open plummeting him into
the dark now go check out scp-2317 the
Devourer of Worlds a door to another
world and scp-2440 the sealed King for
more Eldritch Horrors that will destroy
your mind